trolling is certainly the topic of the
year if we were having this conversation
in 1995 for one thing the screen would
be about 1/16 the size and the video
quality would be much poorer but it
would be a very standard configuration
the story would be hey there's now an
internet people can say anything
sometimes it gets a little out of
control and maybe the government will
come in and try to regulate in some way
but it's basically the government is
trying to stop illegal or really extreme
things from happening and otherwise it's
just a free-for-all out there away we go
fast forward 10 15 20 years and we see
an environment now in which many many
people want to participate maybe have
views they want to share and if you
stick your head up out of the gopher
hole and happened to say something
intemperate
or wrong or that others may disapprove
of they might not just say gee I
disagree let's let's talk about this or
something they may decide to try to
Doc's you find out where you live the
names of the rest of your family to
threaten you with the goal of making you
feel insecure they might try to swat you
tell the police if there's something
terrible going on in your house and
before you know it there's blue and red
lights outside your window and people
ready to kick in the door this is a
strange state of affairs and it's one I
think with multiple causes and that
actually is susceptible to pretty
sustained study most of which hasn't
happened yet in the next few years I
think it will that says what makes
people want to react that way my best
cut on it at the most abstract level is
that when we are online we may be
undertaking very different activities
than the people that we're talking to
one model for being online is I'm
entertaining myself I'm having fun I am
in some form or another playing a game
and if that's the case playing the game
means picking a side and that's a very
different model from I'm online because
I really believe earnestly in something
and I want to convince you of why I'm
right or have you maybe convinced me
or find people who are of like mind and
we can talk about strategizing about the
thing that we really care about those
are totally different activities and
when you try to mix the two it's almost
like saying if there's going to be a
discussion between Seattle Seahawks fans
and New England Patriots fans ahead of a
Superbowl
can't we just settle this with a
discussion like can't we just
earnestly air our differences and come
to some compromise that the Patriots
should win but only by five points like
that's nuts the purpose of the
conversation is sort of just the chest
thumping that comes from the play of
being a fan of a team and trash-talking
the other team and then you know you
play the game I think that for a lot of
trolling there's a sense that it's just
not impersonal we're just out to have
some fun others have referred to this as
4chan culture and of course named after
the site for chann for which this is
largely the culture figured out I think
how to have people avoid category errors
might be a good way to relieve a little
bit the initial conditions that give
rise to a situation that you
fast-forward and somehow death or rape
threats are being made personal
information is getting scattered
everywhere and the party's behind it
still are just like think it's no big
deal
like they just go to sleep at night and
tomorrow they'll find a new cause to get
involved in I imagine we will also see
some of these intermediary platforms
that are commonly used for many purposes
like Twitter they're gonna start taking
a heavier hand at intervening when
discussions get rough and it might be as
simple as being more willing to delete
accounts which let's be clear that's
gonna mean that others will be more
willing to try to importune twitter to
delete accounts as part of the battle
between people who are arguing about
something over the longer term I think
we may see coming into view something's
been promised for a while and be careful
what you ask for I think we're gonna get
it which is to say some form of singular
or multi-platform reputation
systems think how different once Twitter
or Facebook experience might be if the
feed is populated on the basis of people
who are known to participate with a bare
minimum of civility let's define it
easily as don't engage in serious and
imminent death threats and if you do you
might not have your account deleted but
you will find that the way in which you
tweet will not have the same reach as
people who either through the Twitter
platform or through behavior on other
platforms that has been deemed civil and
productive those will start to get reach
- and I will say that once people kind
of know the basis on which they're being
graded can have a really instant effect
on their behavior some of us may
remember the moment that uber mistakenly
made it easy for somebody to find his or
her own rating as a passenger by drivers
on uber drivers rate passengers not just
the other way around and people are much
more self-conscious now maybe about how
they'll behave in an uber if they want
to retain a good rating so that they
will be more likely to be picked up when
they need a cab or a ride in the future
those reputation systems both hold
promise as a way of having trolling the
if not punished not rewarded good
behavior
whatever that means is in the eyes of
the people rating rising you up in the
scales and giving you more reach and of
course also carries with it a whole host
of new and difficult questions about
well who runs this rating system and
what if the people rating me or rating
me by criteria that are unfair that
might be based on the color of my skin
or my ethnicity or something like that
that we could find rating systems doing
now we're just not exactly there yet so
we have to see well what are the
solutions it'll come about - problems
like trolling and one of the problems
that those solutions will